before creation itself there were six
singularity
orange into infinity stone
this is our first day here we are fine
with atlanta and it's it's actually
pretty unbelievable day one of what
promises to be a years of fun-filled
lensing I remember actually going to see
the first Avengers one of my best mates
from home and I'd never have dreamed
that I'd ever be in one of these movies
loans playing spiderman I feel like I'm
on top of the world because this is just
mind-blowing what we always try to do a
marvel studios were building the
Cinematic Universe is look at the big
picture
how can things related across movies and
across the years
Avengers infinity war is the culmination
of the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
has started in may have 2008 with early
spider-man want and it really is an
unprecedented culmination of a series of
film interlinked together which at the
time had never been done before and for
us the important thing is making it all
come together we know they're going to
face them
we've been setting that up since
Avengers 1 how do you do that in a way
that is unexpected that hits the
Avengers against somebody who's more
powerful than a male face and yet make
them completely unprepared to faces
well tear them apart which is why we did
civil war for infinity one as we were
conceiving it and executing Civil War
the end of that movie was very much set
up for what he believes would be we
always had that sense of that
Tony's not talking to Steve the Avengers
are basically a name with nobody in it
the world is vulnerable Tony senses with
greater threat approaching and so he is
doing everything in his power to keep
your safe
panel shows why he's the biggest the
best the baddest villain that we've ever
had and the most frightening villain of
the Avengers of everything
the most exciting part is the incredible
roster of well dissolved characters and
it's going to create a really
combustible exciting massive scale
adventure you know that we're onto
something within the studio when we hit
upon an idea or we see people concept
art and all of us in the room go to
school and in adventures any war
Avengers will meet the garden to the
gallon
because of what Marvel is because of
what they have done over the last 10
years these next two Avengers stones
will be in exactly one of those seen on
film
as promised charter running a little
late you know night shooting at all
hey guys i'm here on the set of
adventures infinity wars this movie's
gonna be so epic
it's so big in fact that i had a up my
game a bit for this one so i got my own
camera died just always be around set
they had fans camera guy so today I'm
here to answer your questions
alright facebook we got to me so i would
like the most about being back with the
Vengeance well I i can't give too much
away but I mean this literally feels
like the second greatest story ever told
and there's so many characters and so
much interesting story so many surprises
and if you could have any other Iron Man
armor which one would you like to take
this day I still finally remember the
mark 42 from iron man 3 excellent
question
keep rolling and are you in Captain
America still not getting along
that is correct he is on my s list i'm
blowing through these I mean
and while we keep going where the rest
of the questions now hearing clicking
camera guys struggled a little bit what
has changed most men Tony Stark since
the first time
well I guess he's a mature a little bit
and I think it changes the universe
around him honestly if you think about
it right
I mean there's so many offshoots now
Peter Parker's in the mix guardians are
on fire
what's your favorite thing about waking
up and playing on them
you know a certain cred that I don't
deserve I'm definitely not as cool as he
is but sometimes I look in the mirror
and I go to just just keep it Tony and
everything's going to be alright
hey amendment oh my God we're ready for
you ready something that's great Joe and
Cantonese Russo I know you guys are
ready but I'm doing a little thinking
taking your questions from the fans
facebook like say hello to the world
hey everybody they're running their
whole dog and pony show some Facebook
are you aren't your camera and set I'm
gonna use my gosh no no no no let's move
on we recognize that conveys my
cameraman for that brother hibiki we got
a killer looks like it might be any
adventure of Marvel's which one would
you be
I'm sorry was that we have so what
you're doing anything to the hero who
would you be good at the agent at
answering his questions your answers as
the Arcanum and it is my guide you just
stir up stories that you know like an
intern on your pc guy answers that you
just the country i think after that
functionality suggest you know you guys
could take a raincheck adventures on a
family vacation who would you take 30
adventures on a family vacation and we
have to say starts to be here
yeah so what we're work you can go
anywhere with what we take that
particular pocket probably probably
absolutely you know it's strange be
allowed to offer you a bunch of
destinations right wormhole it is not
too familiar with and also that will be
great value on vacation
powers and abilities like to serve like
this with no playing on the beach
umbrella yes yeah vision open up a
two-man tent next to more gentle right
and since you brother few guys ever
argue on set when you're directing now
Ellis have you ever witnessed the fight
between us i have not I have not even
seen the mildest of tensions
usually this perfect
hey thanks for all the great questions
yes but we got to get out of the room
yes but what are on the script pages
I mean these pages right here yeah let
me do it all tonight this final page of
the screenplay
he said it says the ends right here at
the bottom oh my god when all our baby's
alive freezing right now
oh no don't really have to write it out
what we talked about that talked about a
little bit okay
yeah five minutes okay and alright that
great heart sinks make sure i think
there are you kidding me thinking of me
really enjoy everybody text thank you
but bad luck hangman and reflections yes
that you know what I will take just one
one more question
yeah we are we have someone here wanting
to ask whether spider-man will be in
this movie you answer that one
I don't know if i can say i will put out
with my camera guy
it's pretty safe to say that he's going
to be in the movie we're gonna have a
lot of stress
okay face but there is one little nugget
for yes I got a girl before I let
anything else you know every student at
night out of the bag and 100 shooting
try next
yeah yeah they called the percent you
know constant what are you doing own up
in this little facebook life you know
people ideas you can question your homie
we were there any questions for me
everybody is Charlie to emergency post
robert downey jr surprised everyone
think hey I have a special announcement
to make
so he just waxes gets really funny about
adventures of Pippi were excited about
filming it but then throws to his quote
unquote camera guy who is spider-man
himself Tom Holland confirming his
presence in the film everybody was
wondering about it
this is probably the studio's way to
just come right out and say it look
everybody's wondering we saw a picture
of Tom Holland a beanie earlier today
here he is in its chris pratt star-lord
walks in in costume
just confirming the e is also in the
movie so it is all cards on the table so
new round of the Marvel give away just
because this is so crazy
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll do a follow up video this
weekend we can freak out so everybody
just go crazy in the comments this is so
awesome
the whole bunch of stuff coming this
weekend is going to be great